[Musica]
[Applauso]
nei tratti del mercato macola ad accra
ghana aprono i loro negozi alle sedie
mattina quando sono deve ancora soci
organizzano inoltre sui tipica degli uni
sugli altri eliminano comprende l'intera
parete del negozio quando entri nome di
mian che i colori del muro ha un effetto
ipnotico
i colori sono bellissimi e ciascuna
stoffa viene accompagnata con un
racconto ci sono ragioni profondi a quei
racconti ben oltre la speranza di
concludere una vendita quando le doti mi
racconta nella storia del tessuto rumors
wars non stanno semplicemente cercando
di sedurre un acquirente ma è come se
stesse essere di fronte a me come se
fossero migliaia di fili le storie delle
donne che 150 anni fa hanno contribuito
a plasmare l'identità di una nazione
chi l'avrebbe mai detto che questi figli
avrebbero potuto cambiare la traiettoria
dell'industria il futuro di una nazione
chi l'avrebbe mai detto di cui si fine
avrebbero creato un senso di libertà lì
dove una volta c'era la paura fuori dal
castello di elimina costruito del
portoghese alla fine del 1400 per essere
il lago più grande per la tratta degli
schiavi tra l'europa l'africa e
l'america
ho conosciuto altre storie storie di
sfruttamento storie di paura storia di
oppressione camminava sulle pietre nere
della sua spiaggia riflettendo sulle
morire della mia cittá natale venezia
quel mourinho e che sono cresciuta
collezionando addossando equivalevano al
prezzo di uno schiavo questo bellissimo
minuscolo e coloratissimo g8 di vetro
poi deve essere scambiato per acquisire
ogni diritto sulla libertà di un altro
essere umano
com'era possibile che un oggetto una
perla potesse essere scambiate
insomma gli europei hanno operato delle
economie africane utilizzando un modello
chiamato ganz le il sacco un circolo
vizioso dove gli africani venivano
ricompensati con tessuti morin e liquori
ed armi in cambio degli individui più
forti che venivano poi venduti come
schiavi
in questo modello tutti vengono messi
quattro tutti gli africani per
difendersi avevo bisogno d'armi e queste
potevano essere ottenute solo dagli
europei che glie ne rendevano in cambio
gli schiavi quando ero a sprint venne
introdotta per la prima volta in africa
a metà del 1800 erano stop inspirate
albatech indonesiano ma prodotta in
serie degli stampi e c'era questi
tessuti erano chiamati manches e fuori
il nome deriva dalle prime fabbriche
inglesi che stampano le work sprint come
molti altri prodotti rappresentavano per
gli europei l'opportunità di trarre
profitti sfruttando le economie africane
queste strade di sfruttamento le
conosciamo tutti ma il mercato di macola
ho scoperto come i fili della speranza
portava per la libertà i disagi proposti
dagli europei a fine del 1800 per lennon
rifiutati dai commercianti e si volevano
invece stampe che parlassero della loro
storia e che incorporassero il loro
patrimonio storico e culturale
così facendo è ora che sono lo story
telling lo strumento principale per la
vendita e l'acquisto dei tessuti
queste donne incorporavano nei tessuti
le loro tradizioni dei loro prudente e
le loro storie
così facendo reso visibile l'intangibile
nelle loro mani questi tessuti
diventarono potenti simboli di identità
che status questa fretta al motivo della
mano
possiamo vedere 12 punti al centro del
palmo aperto e queste simboleggiano
becchi band inglesi il significato di
questa wall street è sposati a mani
vuote
un avvertimento alle giovani donne per
garantire loro l'indipendenza
finanziaria prima del matrimonio
quest'altra sprint invece è dedicata al
servizio della tv di kofi annan il lusso
è diplomato paese le stampe raffigurano
quelle che possono essere viste come
alberi o cervelli poi cosa vedete tra
mary charlie hore eni neuronali la mode
tessuti rimangino centrali nella cultura
ghanese nell'era post coloniale negli
anni cinquanta che poi portarono
all'indipendenza del garda nel regno
unito il vestirsi bene era una strategia
per contrastare i presupposti razzisti
dell'inferiorità africana il boom della
sprint non a caso ho raggiunto nel 1957
quando il primo ministro e presidente
comic roma fu eletto utilizzando la
trama della razione per creare
l'industria del web sprint queste
pioniere creare una traiettoria diversa
per se stesse e il loro paese e se non
guardavano i tessuti per quello che
erano per quello che avrebbero potuto
essere un veicolo per riaffermare
l'identità africana e creare prosperità
nell'era post coloniali le scelte di
queste donne rappresentano quello che fu
il primo passo verso l'abbandono delle
tracce coloniali che per troppo tempo
avevano tolto il valore alla cultura e
al lavoro africani
ecco perché 150 anni dopo questi tessuti
sono chiamati african prezzi e non
maxter club nel 2015 quando andai in
ghana per la prima volta ero incuriosito
dalle statistiche che dicono che
l'africa ha il tasso più alto di
imprenditori al mondo e la maggior parte
di questi imprenditrici sono donne
conoscevo bene il modello di
imprenditori della silicon valley ma non
avevo cognizione di quello africano
finché non andrà il mercato dà maggior
parte dei commercianti sono donne
vendono di tutto e iniziano l'attività
perché questa è l'opportunità primaria
di lavoro
i guadagni giornalieri vengono spesi
immediatamente per sostenere il business
dei propri famiglie e i suoi definire
quando vendono alle bellissime max plank
i loro guadagni sono minimi perché la
maggior parte del ricavato va ai
produttori europei l'indipendenza
culturale che quello notato 150 anni fa
è stata raggiunta ma sono ben nota da
raggiungere la stessa libertà economica
a cui aspirava questo è il figlio della
libertà come ispira ad affondare macola
per investigare su come in quello che
indossiamo possa diventare un mezzo per
influenzare i cambiamenti sociali ed
ambientali per creare un eco prosperità
quando gioca da oca artista e attivista
giapponese americana di fama
internazionale ha interpretato con il
flauto presso sword per la cerimonia del
novantesimo compleanno di martin luther
king a stanford aggiustato un abito ma
con ha realizzato da gioco maastricht
indossando quell'abito per ricordare il
martin luther king
un uomo che ha combattuto la
disuguaglianza razziale tra la propria
vita e guidate movimenti civili in
america
giù anche il cerchio ha deciso di
continuare il filo della libertà
che vive attraverso così gesù
[Musica]
le venditrici dell'africa occidentale
non avrebbero mai potuto immaginare che
l'identità ei valori dei loro tessuti un
giorno avrebbero potuto far parte di una
cerimonia per ricordare l'uomo per
combattuto per la libertà dei loro
fratelli padri
[Musica]
ogni volta che vado al mercato di macola
penso alle donne che fecero questi li
cent'anni prima di me quando ascoltavano
le storie delle venditrici si sarebbero
mai immaginate che stanno costruendo una
cultura prima un movimento pochi avranno
portato all'inizio dell'inverter si di
secoli di sfruttamento
ogni volta che hanno comprato un tessuto
hanno costruito hanno partecipato
qualcosa di più grande che non si
sarebbero mai potuto immaginare
ed è qui che le wall street diventano un
veicolo per vedere come compressione e
libertà possano sovrapporsi ma poi
spetta a noi decidere come continuare
questo filo e se ogni scelta che
facessimo avesse lo stesso potere le
nostre vite sono attraversate da molte
cambi di libertà di chi spesso non siamo
a conoscenza perché più facile vedere
quello che ci sta vicino
ed è esattamente in questo momento che
le nostre azioni e non azioni fanno la
differenza
il mondo interconnesso in cui viviamo ci
dà l'opportunità di utilizzare le
informazioni per dare più valore alle
vittorie che sono venuti prima di noi
così poi possiamo continuare queste
gemme di libertà
ogni voto ogni acquisto ogni posto sui
social media ogni business al potere di
definire nuove traiettorie che possono
attraversare generazioni continua
e che possono trasformare sciami di
paura in fiamme di libertà grazie
[Risate]